howdy folks Maxwell here with a breaking  news update the first images of the  controller for Amazon's rumored set-top  box have just surfaced the images come  by way of noted blogger Dave zat's who  claims to have scooped them from an  overseas regulatory agency the button  layout looks fairly standard and mimics  the button and analog stick setup of  other controllers but with the addition  of media playback buttons the home menu  and back buttons are using Android style  icons based on earlier information the  streaming device is believed to run a  modified version of Android and there is  a central button that will presumably  connect you to Amazon game circle  service it was previously unclear if the  rumor box would support gaming but it  seems very likely now that the  controller images have surfaced and of  course you can learn more about this  developing story by heading on over to  gamespot com and clicking on the news  tab